i've done this uh this this videos
before i've done it with uh
khalil and so on yeah right and i got a
lot of backlash uh
that we had to do a reaction video to
actually clear our name because uh even
like the basics of sex
they make a reaction video but
unfortunately
they were not educated enough on their
own history neither were they educated
on their own religion and they
misinterpreted us they strong enough and
delight just
basically a lot
me and carl went back and forth to
see if we wanted to do this
because they were leaders and we don't
want to spoil your name but since
they they were trying to do that to us
so we had to clear our name so this was
the reason why we did it
so if there's any questions that anyone
who watches this video any sick watches
this video if you have any questions you
want to clear up that if you think that
i'm lying or making anything up
i will share with the brothers over here
the link and you can go and watch those
videos because we we explain everything
there from the own sikhi scholars
not from a muslim scholar
not from a christian scholar from your
own sikhy scholars itself let me go into
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the realest podcast in the dunya the
three muslims we're not joined with rami
but it's still three muslims
so how's it going man
alhamdulillah
can't complain
bro you're one of the very few sikh
reverts to islam that i know
so uh do you want to tell us a little
bit about your journey
yes you're right brother um
the religion of sick or the belief of
sick
they hall uh their beliefs very strongly
and it's very very close to islam
right so uh
just before i go into uh sharing my
story just one and we want to actually
understand what citizen believe right
now
in the many names of god
allah is also one of the name of god in
sikhism
right
yes
not many people know this right they um
and it's not just a generic name like
god
allah is
for them
yes
in the ggs
yes in the ggs um
in fact in in in the ggs the fifth guru
guru arjun dev
he said that the one god the lord of
this world is my god allah
now that's a translation but if you uh
take it uh rawly right it says
gosanya now gosanya is another word that
hindu calls god
but what i want to emphasize here is
at the end he says it's my god allah
so the word allah has mentioned that
there right
they believe
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is a true prophet
right he was sent by allah
this is all
something that they believe
right my journey
to islam started
when i was about 15 years old
and other than being just not a normal
15 years old doing all my
15 year old things
you know teenagers do
i decided to uh look into
the guru granth sahib so i studied the
guru granth sahib
and i was
and it's once again i would just like to
go on a record this is my own personal
journey i'm not saying anyone is wrong
right i don't want anyone to take any
offense because in islam we have been
taught by our prophet and by allah
himself to respect the belief of others
so i'm not here to belittle anyone's
belief all respects to everyone
having said that to me personally i did
not feel that um it is enough
i could not comprehend the idea of uh
god being
everything and everyone
pantheism so this led me to look at
other religions
i went to hinduism
that's
quite straightforward
i went to buddhism they don't believe in
god so that's quite straightforward and
there was no point looking at atheists
or being an agnostic because i was very
sure that there is a creator
and i was very sure of that so i never
even went into that those those
ideologies
so i went to judaism
uh apparently jews have this thing that
where they say that if you are not born
a jew then you can convert to being a
jew so what can i do
um
and then i went to christianity so uh
interesting i i i went to christianity i
went to churches i spoke to them i spoke
to the priests i spoke to the to the
padres and all
and
they what they were telling me was not
what the bible was saying
so i found this very interesting right
then i started to look into uh youtube
videos
and speakers corner
all these right now it's like why wait a
minute something
did you find him
uh
i met jack rush once okay okay later
once right uh but i did not really speak
anything i mean was more on a casual
talk it wasn't anything to do about
religion
um
so then i decided to to just look a
little bit deep into the bible and i i
found this versus uh even before knowing
even before knowing right that uh we
don't know who the author of the gospels
were and and so on and there were
changes and there were uh corruptions
done to the bible
i saw this verse that john 2017 where
jesus actually says
he says i'm going to
your father and my father to your god
and my god
right so
okay that's done for me
all right that's done for me
he himself is admitting that he has a
god right i'm not gonna listen to anyone
else he's the guy saying he has a god
right
so that was done so then then um
then well
left with only islam
so uh
amazingly it was very hard for me to
actually
accept islam to even open the quran to
it would start to look at where islam is
coming from i just decided to you know
what i'm just going to chill for a while
right um
i was given a quran by a friend i was in
my dorm at that time
everyone was away
and i was super bored and the only
entertainment that i have was reading
the quran because i had no any other
book so i said
let me just look at the quran let me see
what is this
what what is what's the quran talking
about
so open to the first verse i
read a little bit and i came to the to
the part in surah al-baqarah where allah
actually says
whoever allah wish to guide will be
guided and whoever allah does not wish
to be guided will not be guided for
their allah wail in front of their eyes
and tower up their hearings they will
never be guided
i asked then then allah here ask myself
one question
how do i know if i'm if i'm being guided
or not how do i make that distinction
like like how do you know this right
it's not like i can whatsapp allah and
ask him
yo am i being guided or not
i can't do that
so um
i put the the quran aside for a while
and i said okay so logically
let's look at this individual
called muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam right because he makes a lot of
claim he says
allah sends him he says he's a prophet
he says he received revelation
right
now if this person i want to be i'm just
making a point huh
if this person is just simply saying
things and he and whatever he's saying
cannot be true i don't even have to
waste my time looking in the quran but
whatever if whatever this person is
saying is true
then by default the quran is real
it's authentic and everything else is
false yeah
right so
i looked into his life
so let's let's go through the journey
with me right
brothers and sisters
um
here's a man
who's known as al-amin
for 40 years
right
no one today
right or in any time for 40 years can be
known as the trusted one
they will i mean as men we are not
perfect we would do something
rather here and there right
but people used to leave their
belongings with him they used to go for
travels they used to come back and
everything would still be there
all right 100
right and then uh he was married to one
of the richest women in mecca of the
year
uh
his uh family was the custodians of the
kaaba right even the uncle who brought
him up he was the leader of the kaaba
right
so
this person didn't track me that he had
he wanted any political gain
that he wanted any name from himself
because what he did
did not give him what a politician would
want
because he rather lost all of that he
was prosecuted he was
given threats of murder
it became so bad for him that he had to
leave the place where he born where he
was born
right
and go away from there
uh it was a time where uh the
authorities in makkah said that no one
is allowed to sell
them any kind of food muhammad and the
followers right
no one's allowed to so this you know if
someone who who's already who's really
in a prestige
part of life
he has money he has a family right is he
has status
this is not something
what you would do to gain more as we see
today politicians that is not what they
would do
right
but he continued uh
doing it so okay
but then uh this person
he can't be just making up these things
right so
now
could it be that he was deceived
would he be that he was deceived
let's look into this claim
um
if he was deceived as the christians
normally say that he wasn't the angel
opiate right
to him
then
why is it when we look into the quran
it actually talks everything against
right it tells us who is saitan it tells
us the beginning of shaytan he tells us
that this is your clear enemy stay away
from him
to not work with him do not do this we
even start with
him
already my seek refuge
from this
satan
you know if that was the devil who was
doing it that's not a very smart devil
to teach someone something that goes
that doesn't bring him any benefit
and we know that what uh what he says in
the quran what is the promise of the
iblis to allah that
i will let astray all the sons of adam
so that that this couldn't be his motive
if he was
deceiving the prophet
so okay
then maybe uh you know you ask yourself
this question maybe he was doing black
magic
but then to do black magic you would
need to have the idea of of uh doing
things with the gene
which comes from the iblees as well and
the quran clearly says stay away from
you cannot have any kind of
communication or any kind of
relationships with the genes right that
we are to separate
um
maybe he was just making all this up
could it be
impossible
for 23 years this man
was having everything in his head and he
has to hash it out accordingly and the
way
the miracle of the the the ayat and the
way it's it's uh it's it's you know it's
portrayed and all
ben can't do this
and he was illiterate
this is the man who was illiterate okay
fine i i mean i've had i've heard this
argument yeah maybe he was illiterate
but he could remember things and then he
could say it and someone else could
write it
fine
okay i mean it's a logical uh assertion
right
but then this does not explain all the
um
actually when we go to uh one of the
surah where allah talks about um
what was the surah
the the the most evil guy
where allah says
he will never accept islam and he and
his wife will both be in hell
was it
yes this person was alive
when this surah came now this person was
alive now all he needed to do is
all abu lahab needed to do is to
disprove the prophethood of this of this
of our prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and this proof islam is
to accept islam and that seed is gone
because allah says he will never accept
islam and he said yeah i am i'm a muslim
accepted he was alive and he did not
accept islam
right
this is a miracle right and when we talk
about the the embryology
how can men
even modern science today in this
generation can't go that deep into
understanding it and this
it mentions in detail it mentions right
from the gushing of the sperm
how it's how it travels
right where it meets how many how much
of time it takes when the bone starts
when the flesh starts and the whole
thing
so this was definitely not a made-up job
right and even at that time when uh the
enemies of the prophet sent the uh
the people who were the best
poetries people for writing poetry and
to go and listen to the recitation of
the quran
the only conclusion that they came back
with is they say that whatever this man
is saying it cannot be from this world
it's supernatural
akbar and it is it's not from this world
it is from allah
right
so
that leaves me for then to only one
thing that this man was telling the
truth
right this man was telling the truth
but i wasn't very convinced yet you know
i was still i mean i mean i still had
some doubts
i can't really say what doubts probably
is the shaytan but i just couldn't
accept it yet so what i did then was
studied a little bit of dawah
okay and this is not to uh at that time
back in at that time it's not to defend
islam
but what i would do was like what i was
in england for a while i was in
singapore for a while i was in thailand
for a while what i would do is i would
go to a hindu i will go to a pristine
evangelist i will go to a buddhist
and i will uh
start to do da'wah to them
for the reason
for the reason is this
if i am defending islam
and if you can refute it
then islam is false
right so i am new at this so i don't
know so i'll go to the older people who
know how to refute this
so i'll go with all this uh all the
darwah material that i've learned and
i'll present it to them
as if i'm a muslim but
let me just go on i never claimed i was
a muslim at that time they did of course
i mean if you if i come to you and i
start doing that while you would
automatically think that yeah he's a
muslim right
so i did this for about one and a half
year two years
masha allah no one could refute it
whether it was in england whether it was
in singapore australia thailand no one
could refute it
okay
so then
this uh these arguments that the quran
has put out that allah has put out he
says his knowledge is true
then i thought to myself look it'll be
pretty stupid of me to not listen
when my lord is talking to me and
telling me look this is how you need to
live your life in order to be successful
here and to be successful when you
return to him allah right
it'll be stupid of me to be arrogant of
me then i would be no different from the
iblees
i will be no different
right
so then then i took my shahadah
muhammad
accepted islam and um alhamdulillah
17 years later here i am 17 19 this is
17 years ago
yeah so i kept islam when i was 17.
i'm 36 now
19 years here
also question
how was it when you
embarked on
learning about hinduism and stuff like
that to see if that was the truth like
what did you find
uh
to me personally um
i could not comprehend the idea of
having more than one god
right so anyone who has more than one
god i logically for my own logic i
couldn't accept it because look
if there's one god
then it makes sense if there is more
than one god then you have more than one
will
right
so you can't have two mighty powers
fighting with one another that's one
secondly when you say he is the
almighty
then there has to only be one you can't
have two almightys can you
so that's why logically god has to be
only one so um i never really embarked
very much into hinduism as well
because i have a
i have a friend
he's hindu
and uh me and him talked about this one
time
and
i told him i was like bro like how can
you be a part of something that has been
been altered so much and you have all
these different gods like
and
how are they even gods he's like oh well
no they they're not really gods it's a
it's a poor translation i think he said
bhagavan
or something like that
yeah which i guess roughly like the real
translation is supposed to be like
enlightened one or something like that
i don't know
a lot of them but he said something
along those lines
and then he tried to say the claim that
um
the true hindus know that there is only
one guy because if you look at the the
vedas
the the scripts the old scripts it
literally says that there's only one god
but now they have
these different idols if they're not
guys and they're idols was like when did
these idols come apart or come to be and
like why is it that if in the the actual
scripts the vedas the ancient vedas if
it says that there's only one god
why is it that there's all these other
idols and people worship them as if they
were god
yeah you know
it's confusing man it's confusing
it is i i i agree um it's not easy to
understand yes
i think this is what i also i heard in
even in hinduism they believe that god
there's only one supreme god um forgive
me if i'm wrong here it's either a
vishnu or shiva
one of them i don't know which one
and all the others uh basically they are
the the the middle person so you pray to
a statue
right but that's that you actually like
if the middle person is not like v god
but here's the thing right
god is all powerful he created this
whole universe everything that you see
no and you will ever know
come from him he doesn't need a
middle person to send message to him
he doesn't needs that like he knows
everything he even knows what you're
going to ask him before you can ask him
right so why the need for for for a
middle person i actually had this
argument once with a friend of mine
and he said but wait you you guys you
muslims you guys have middle people as
well like all those prophets i say wait
that's
that
that's a misconception
we don't worship our prophets okay our
prophets bring message from allah from
the one true god
okay he brings the message and then he
gives it to the nation
we don't worship so that that's a
misunderstanding over there y'all are
worshiping or uh sending a message to
god
whereas
this is
totally different
the prophet gets the message the
messenger gets the message from god and
then the message is given to us
right so that's how it works so it's not
the same
so
what would
what would you do let's say figuratively
speaking you were in this uh dollar
situation
how you were
back then when you did the two years of
dawah
you ran into someone who was basically
bringing up the same thing
and for them they're telling you
that uh
vishnu
whichever one stuff for allah
that that's god
and that oh because they they know that
that's god well y'all are basically
believing in the same thing just
practicing differently
so like what would you what would you
bring up to them and i know this is a
loaded question like
yeah obviously but
just out of curiosity no problem
inshallah
so yes there's the
many experience
through uh
those years
um
i would normally ask them uh certain key
questions
like for example how do you prove your
god is
through god
is it okay for me to be a muslim or
christian and then pray to your god
or is it okay because it's kind of a
it's kind of a
of a trap for me because when they say
yeah yeah it's okay you can be muslim or
you can be a christian
but you pray to our god there's no
problem okay fine then you can be a
christian or a muslim too right
oh no we cannot why not
why not why is it okay for me and not
okay for you
why is it okay for me to be a muslim or
christian or chinese or buddhist and
pray to your uh
your belief but when it comes to you
you can't be all this you have to be a
hindu
so that's that doesn't make sense over
there right
so you need we need one universal truth
we can't have multiple truths we cannot
have multiple truths and they'll
normally ask why not why can't we have
multiple truths
but because truth is only one
all the others are not
if if one is true then the other is not
you know i mean it's hard to accept but
i'm sorry that's how the way it will
works right
so
then
most of the time they'll
when it comes to these hard questions
for them to answer
they will just then come with uh i'm
sure i'm sure brothers you know this
very well they start to waffling to
waffle like such things like there's
only one god it doesn't matter who you
are who you pray to as long as your
heart is pure
as long as you always think of god is
okay tonight
once once all this starts to come out
okay i know he's done i'm not gonna
continue
right
but if i must say brothers
the best that what i've ever
in that time was with the christians
because
it was entertaining for me
it was really
i'm not trying to be a
because i would i would i would simply
ask them questions like um
i mean once i've i've uh you know have
enough of knowledge so ask them
questions like
why do you believe that jesus is god
and they will say oh because he's the
son of god no no why do you believe that
he's god
because he had to come down and die for
the sins
also the father can't forgive your sins
you know i will ask this kind of you
know i know it's ridiculous to ask this
kind of questions
right but i will just test them with
this you know i'll just test them with
this and i'll see like what are they
what are they going to answer and i'll i
will take out like john you know 3 7
this is now life eternal that they
should know you to be the only true god
you know i said like look in the first
century
second century no one believes in the
trinity
right
uh musa moses
he told the chama
listen israel your lord god our lord is
one god
jesus said the same thing listen israel
our lord god
the quran says the same thing your lord
your lord is one
you're the only odd bears out here
suddenly out i mean not two you came
with three
right you came with three
and um they they kind of and they kind
of they cannot be consistent because
most of the time they say even though
they are three but they are not three
they are one you will never see them
separate you'll never see them wait a
minute
wasn't
when jesus was being baptized
the sky opened and the holy death came
down who the holy dot was the holy
spirit then you had the fathers we have
three different entities at the same
time so that's three they're not one
that's three
right
and your claim is jesus had to be
sinless
for him to die on the cross
okay
why was he being baptized
baptized means the baptize of to get rid
of your sins
right baptism of sins oh no because he
was just uh showing people how to be
what are you talking man
john the baptist was already doing that
long time ago we didn't need to show
right john the baptist already doing
that so
why
a sinless jesus needed to be baptized by
john the baptist
it doesn't make sense i'm sorry really
it doesn't it doesn't so
really
christianity was just quite
straightforward because
um i learned one thing
christianity through going to the to the
churches
which i think that
the culture should be should be
it comes from islam
when you go to church right
masha'allah these people the way they
receive you
oh my brother come come it's like you
have been lost to them you know they've
never met you you've been lost to them
for like 10 years 20 years and you have
suddenly come back oh my brother they'll
come and hug you you need food you can
get coffee for you can i do this come
sit down let me get a chair for you you
know and they really take care of you
and they call you up and they follow up
are you coming to church this sunday do
you need transport do you need anything
right i'll get a grab for you
the way they really take care of you is
baha'u'llah right
it's a very good culture i think more
muslims should adopt this culture
because this
was how our prophet taught us to be
right how can you sleep with a full
stomach while your uh neighbors are on
an empty stomach this is the same
culture right it's the love culture the
culture of caring for others and not
just for yourself
um so that is one thing that i i see
that's very good but when it comes to
the theology it just falls apart okay it
just falls apart like
i would never you know
allah he i am so so glad beyond words
that allah has chosen me out of billion
people to guide to bring to the truth
it's just
there's no words there's no words let me
tell you this and and in return like the
only thing that allah wants from us to
accept us is just monotheism
just accepting one god that that's the
fundamental thing about islam
and what's weird is allah could have
chosen something that is illogical or
something that needs more convincing but
if you're you have a sound logic
and you're not trying to be foolish
anyone can just believe that it's it's
not a contradiction it's not something
that's too difficult it's not something
that's too much of a gamble and that's
all allah requires subhanallah
you come across someone head to head
right now who is a devout sikh
right now he's been sick all his life
he believes uh you know sikhism he was
raised on that
i need you to go into this there's
probably a ton of people that's going to
watch this video that are currently seek
they're like what is this islam thing
right so i want you to break down
sikhism not like i'm not saying
breakdown doesn't destroy it i'm saying
break down as in like
deconstruct it make it easy to
understand use things from the scripture
things that it kind of makes no sense
and then tell me why
there is this weird battle between sikhs
and muslims today like where does this
stem from why do they not accept the
truth is it a cultural thing is it a
political thing is it an ideological
thing
yep
all right uh so i've done this uh this
this videos before i've done it with uh
khalil and so on yeah right and i got a
lot of backlash uh
that we had to do a reaction video to
actually clear our name because even
like the basics of six
they make a reaction video but
unfortunately
they were not educated enough on your
own history neither were they educated
on your own religion and they
misinterpreted us they strongment us and
they lied just
basically a lot
me and khalil went back and forth to
see if we wanted to do this
because they were leaders and we don't
want to spoil your name
but since
they they were trying to do that to us
so we had to clear our name so this was
the reason why we did it
so if there's any questions that anyone
who watches this video and is sick who
watches this video if you have any
questions you want to clear up that if
you think that i'm lying or making
anything up
i will share with the brothers over here
the link and you can go and watch those
videos because we we explain everything
there from their own sikhi scholars not
from a muslim scholar
not from a christian scholar from your
own sikhi scholars itself let me go into
this
the
misunderstanding occurred during the
mughal empire
in india okay
now
when it came to the first mughal empire
they were muslims not
okay they were not good muslims okay
let's just say that because they were
drinking
they were smoking opiums they were they
had like
god knows how many wives right
they were not they were not good muslims
right but nevertheless they were muslims
so um
the first emperor like emperor akbar
who actually apostate from islam and
started his own religion called dini
right
now he was very good with everyone all
the race he went uh visited a guru nanak
right he even visited all the other
gurus who was of course alive in his
time
uh
i don't want to go into the whole
history then um
we get uh emperor jahangim
now this is where it starts
because emperor jahangir is the one who
actually called for the execution of the
fifth guru guru arjun dev
and guru arjun dev he did a lot
okay he supported a lot of muslims he uh
so he he built of or finished
the the the temple the golden temple or
the harmander sahib which is in punjab
is the
quote and quote unquote the
kaaba for the the sikh so the most
holiest grounds for the sake yeah
so he was on so um and not only that he
uh just
uh you know like
executed him he tortured he make sure
that he was tortured
and
here's the misunderstanding
now
they say that
jahangir
forced
the guru to accept islam and this was
the reason because the guru did not
wanted to accept islam this was the
reason
that the emperor ordered his uh
execution
that story has a little fabrication and
a little exaggeration to it i still i
still hear that story till today bro
yep it's still still in everyone's minds
yeah
but um
okay i want to put it into context okay
i want to put it into context and i want
everyone to understand how the flow
did he yes he did
asked the uh guru to convert to islam
yes he did but it was not for religious
purposes it was mainly for political
purposes why
this is what happened
see bismillah
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zordsis we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin so you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
one of his son i think i'm not mistaken
rebelled against his father
and he was bringing his army to dethrone
his father
right
it so happened that he stopped at the uh
the village i would just say village the
village where uh
guru arjun they owned that village okay
now being a man of god being a humble
man
right
he accepted them he gave them food and
he blessed them
okay like any normal like god bless you
go on your journey be safe that's about
it but when this story came to the
emperor
the story was said
your son is coming to kill you and the
gurus bless them
he immediately thought
okay so you are committing treason
this person is coming to kill me and you
supported him and you blessed him on top
of that
to kill me so it was a misunderstanding
so let me ask you this question back in
that time
right not only the muslims not only the
sake
let's look at the roman empire the
chinese empire all empire the kings
right in that time when you commit
prison there's only one thing that
happens you either get to run away
or you die
there is there is no other way
you're going to some countries today
even that's the thing
exactly
right so
he immediately uh told his soldiers to
capture the guru
right
and he told the guru
accept islam now
or i will kill you
because once you accept islam he as the
leader
right
you then
there is no way for you to take the
throne his drone
right like even if kusuro uh wins
right or uh
jahangir uh kills kuzrow kusala would
have not win because
army was very small
right
but you are still here so
if you are here and you convert to islam
you have no choice then
to follow the king because you can't
claim prophethood or you can't claim
anything to say that
it is my throne and it's my right
because once you're a prophet then the
land belongs to you the people belongs
to you no i mean not in terms of belongs
i mean you're the leader
automatically
right
so
this is what what that happened it was a
misunderstanding so of course the guru
said no i will not accept islam
right and so he tortured the guru
and
he murdered the guru right he wanted the
guru now let's look from the islamic
standpoint of peace right because i want
every sikh
brothers and sisters out there to
understand
islam
from the quran
islam from the prophet muhammad
does not teach this
allah makes it very clear in the quran
there is no compulsion in this religion
there is no
okay
now men are left to do
what they want to do your free will
right
so you can't really say that oh no
jahangir forced uh you know all these
muslims they are forcing everyone to
convert no
do we condone this as learned muslims
what jahangir did no we don't we condemn
it
he had no right to force anyone because
it was not his call it was allah's call
okay and he has no right to kill anyone
before a proper trial
but like i say he was not a proper
muslim so basically at that time when
you're a king you do what you want to
so that was the first misunderstanding
they thought that his actions represent
islam
they thought they yeah i think a lot of
people till today still thinks that
right like someone uh like isis people
still look at isis and say look these
are the muslims
no
right i always say look just because
someone straps a bomb to them and go and
kill someone and before they bomb
themselves up they say allahu akbar
right that doesn't represent islam
just because someone's running around
and saying allahu akbar doesn't
represent islam
you see so you need to know what islam
is before just pointing your fingers and
saying things that are just simply
ridiculous you know
islam has nothing to do with isis
nothing
so um
then the second was aaron zeb now
aaron zapp is actually the center of the
problem that you the reason that bjp
government today
are going against the muslim going
against the sikh are going even against
your own hindu people and they are like
you know whatever
modi is doing
right the bjp government is it all comes
it starts from here from this person
right he was the most strongest emperor
and out of all the
the mughal empire he was the most
islamic
right he was the most islamic we know
this why because he used to pray
right he used to uh that there is um
there is a writing in his memoirs where
someone wrote and said
that this aran zab
while
war was going on he would have stopped
and prayed
this was the time of prison
right
so uh
allah knows best
right so anyway out of all he was the
the the most islamic of them
there are many stories about this uh he
butchered thousands of hindus
he broke thousands of temples
right so that's why the hindus hate
hate him to hate him
but let's look at the scholar by the
name of aldridge rashki
audi trustee who is a historian who is i
think she is a christian on 80s i i
don't know what's her belief but she's
definitely not a hindu she's not from
india
right but she has done in-depth studies
she has she knows how to even read the
um
the uh what is the ancient
the ancient uh writings right of the
hindus she have learned that so she know
how to read it she knows
sunscreen sunscreen
sunscreen uh she wants to read pashto
and all that
now
she has done an intense research on this
individual
and this is what she says
did aaron zeb go out and kill
many hindus
yes he did
but is it to say that he killed
thousands of hindus that is an
exaggeration
did hindus go out and kill the hindus
yes they did
because
it was the time of war
so what has been done here for to to to
diminish this person's name is to say
all the wars that he fought and the
people that he killed right they took it
and they say that this person went on a
killing spree of hindus
right
there you go right they just twist the
whole thing up
right uh
did he break temples yes he did they
said that he they broke in thousands he
broke thousands of hindu temples once
again
that's an exaggeration
after the counting
he only broke up to maybe 20 to 30
temples and he did this
it was like i say once again it was a
battle strategy and it was a kind of a
political strategy so what happens in
india is
when they go to a place because
in a certain place like for example
banaras
right
everyone over there they put their faith
they put their belief in this one uh
temple in this one um
their god right there who are who they
believe to be god
so
when they come and they break this this
uh these statues and they break up the
temple
right it demotes
the motivation of the soldiers like look
the person that you believe the the
entity that you believe is gonna is
gonna you know help you
is gone
what you're gonna do now so it was more
of on that it was nothing to do with
religion at all right and we know that
he did this why because once again our
name benares
now panaras is full of hindu temples
now we know he went to banaras he broke
one temple he broke two temples
but
there are lines of temples
right
out of that whole lines of temples 20 30
temples he only broke two or three now
if he wanted if he was going around
breaking hindu temples it would be much
more easier for him to break all the
temples in that one place why did he
only break two three
he was four deaths for this particular
reason
he was not interested in in uh taking
his energy and breaking all the temples
he was just trying to demotivate the
people over there and the soldiers over
there
so when they motivated what happens they
don't fight
and you surrender
because when you do fight then
well
we'll have to fight and then probably we
will kill you
that's how it works in war
you don't kiss someone when someone's
coming to kill you that's just
ridiculous right i mean that's how it
works right so
that's how they painted this the picture
that he went on the killing spree for
hindus he hated hindus he was a racist
um the other thing is
uh
arangzab
they say that he murdered his own family
his three brothers
is it true yes it's true
but let's look again at the context
he was not the only mughal to do that
his father shah jahan did that this for
the jahangir did that because it was
the culture that was the culture once
the king dies
the brothers or the men in the family
would have to fight for the power
and fight
they have to kill their own siblings
until they're the only one left and then
they become the emperor that was just
how it is don't ask me what's so funny
right that's just how it is so
he himself did this in fact when he when
he caught his elder brother
all right and his elder brother knew
that he was going to die aaron asked him
one one and this is once again it's in
the memories of our another asking this
what would you do
if you was in my place
and the brother did not like to even say
i would kill you
right
so so okay all his brothers was there
then he imprisoned his father
for what i think what six seven eight
years or twenty years or something i
know not twenty years can't really
remember how many years but for a long
time imprisoned his father and they say
like
look at this man how evil is he to
imprison further less once again look at
the context this was the same man who
hated this person this was his son
multiple times he sent his son out to go
and fight for war hoping that he would
die there
and if he does not die he would send
people to go and kill him
so what difference now that i'm the king
wouldn't you try even harder to kill me
right the very fact that he said that i
will not kill you
why do they they will never say this
this is what he told it further
you will be here in the red fort
right
you can ask for anything you want
anything
you shall have it
but your freedom you will never have
this is what aaron said to his father
anything you want you can have but not
your freedom obviously the guy was
afraid of his life
right because if he let the old king go
don't you think his
uh parliament will still be there his
influence will still be there
right that's not a very intelligent
thing to do
for for their time in india their their
ideology right
now what did this person did why does uh
shiki
has a
bitter taste in history with this person
as well
he
executed the ninth guru which is
right
and um
uh
son which is uh the tenth guru
guru har guru har
his children
were um
was cement alive
right and they just left the bodies
there
now there are various stories to this
number one
when
the execution of guru tej bahadur
happened
okay there are sources that say
that aaron zapp was not even in delhi
he was off fighting the bataans
and of course he would give his general
the rights you go ahead take care of
whatever you need to take taking care of
do whatever that needs to be done
because i need to go and fight a war
right you can't be
disturbing me at that time
so
they executed guru tegh bahadur and they
uh like i said they killed his
grandchildren as well
um
so you see
the the gurus are very very close
to uh sikhi
right they're very close
uh some
some might call them a
reincarnation of god
some call them prophets right whatever
you know
whatever it may be
they are very close they are very
high rank people in the sick uh belief
when you have people killing them of
course you're gonna have a problem now
try to put ourselves
to try to understand them in their shoes
just for a while
okay
and um
right
imagine if someone this would have not
happened but imagine if someone would
have murdered any of our prophet
we probably hate them too
we'll probably dislike them too
okay
but this has these are things that
happened what 500 years ago 400 years
ago
right and and things have changed so
much from them
right and
like we say this is not that is what
islam has taught this is not the real
true teachings of allah
right to simply go around and kill
people because what does the quran says
once again the quran allah says clearly
saving one man
saving one life is as if saving the
whole of humanity
right
and killing one innocence life is as if
killing the fall of humanity
right
so this is
it's very clear
it's very clear right
things happen back in those times
people fought people killed each other
right people could kill each other
because they were not worshipping the
same god people kill each other because
you were looking at my sister strangely
people kill each other because you you
owe them a certain amount of money
people kill life
was very cheap back then
it was very easy people could just kill
you because they didn't like the way you
look
okay if you i mean how you're gonna
control that you're born that you ended
and someone didn't like the way you look
and if you couldn't protect yourself
they would kill you
so
you know um
that that that is the uh is is the
problems or the misconceptions that has
been happening and
many sikhs
unfortunately
they i they have not looked into this
deeply
they have probably looked at the surface
but not deeply into it and they and and
if you want to do this research
logically you need to not only look at
your own sources you need to look at the
hindu sources you need to look at the
muslim sources
and then you can come to a conclusion
from all all the sources right
um not to degrade or not to say anything
wrong
i have sick friends till today i just
did a show with them today morning
right
uh i have zoom uh talked with them the
one that i did is the president of the
youth use fake malaysian president right
i respect them they are they are good
people you know they they stand up for
the right things they protect people
right
they don't like
you know they always support their
community they're good people
but
for the modern or the other generations
or the the ones who have this uh
misunderstanding towards islam
uh there are many claims that can be
made
the many claims and yes one of the
biggest claim made is that
guru nanak went to makkah okay he went
to makkah and then um the khadi saw him
because he was sleeping his feet was
pointing towards the taba
so the kazi sauce saw him and
they did not like it so they carry his
feet and they moved and they moved his
feet and when they moved his feet
the kaaba followed the feet
right
fine you can say
a claim make a claim of course no
problem but let's look at the history
does history show that the kaaba has
been moved no
okay this was about islam was already
about 1 000 years in 900 to 1 000 years
in so hajj was very popular already
people was coming from around the world
i think i guess it would be the ottoman
empire at that time in charge of the
kaaba
probably 500 years ago
should be i think i think the if i'm not
wrong if i'm not wrong would be the
ultimate so
yeah
it would it would have been already a
lot of people doing coming to the kaaba
you are telling me
no one
who is in the masjid al-haram at that
time no one
wrote this down
there were hundreds and thousands of
muslims in the kaaba no one wrote this
down
and guru nanak himself did not write
this down
right it was written by uh
where his writing is in the guru granth
sahib but he was not part of the gurus
he was not part of the ten gurus
right uh
i forgot his name he is the only person
who wrote this down
the only person who wrote this down even
guru nanak himself did not write this
down guru nanak had a very very good
companion who followed him around they
were like
they were like brothers his name was
who was
a muslim
he was born he born as a muslim he lived
as a muslim he died as a muslim
right
he would have known about this did he
write it down no
do we have his writing in the guru
granth sahib today in the ggs yes
the guru's added his writing into the
guru into the ggs
did they talk anything about this none
neither guru nanak spoke about this
neither did guru nanak sorry
um
spoke about this
only gurdesh his name is i think i'm not
mistaken right
if i'm not wrong forgive me if i'm wrong
right
only this one person writes down about
it
right only this one person writes down
about it so of course fine no problem if
this is the claim that you want to make
produce your evidence
right if you are
because look even in the quran allah
says this
right bring your evidence if you're
truthful
so we are not saying you are wrong we
are not
dismissing you
of course you must understand it's hard
for us to believe this
right you can go to a hindu and say this
and then expect him to believe that you
can go to
a uh
what
a christian and say this and expect him
to believe that so of course it's for us
as muslim will be hard to believe it but
bring us produce your proof
because in our history there is not
written
it's not written
and i know probably you you would say
like of course all the hundreds and
thousands of people were muslim of
course they were not going to write this
so you are saying that all the hundreds
and thousands of muslims
were deceiving all the other muslims
not even one of them
were truthful out of these hundred and
thousands of muslims the imam over there
so you are basically saying all muslims
over there were corrupted come on that's
a big claim to do to make bro you know
we don't want to cause any kind of
problems here yeah yeah go ahead
okay i had a question so given that
we're kind of short on time so i'm
thinking that you know how like
ahmadiyya you know they they had their
own agenda it's not islam they they
started you know there's the british
history we're not going to get into that
but i'm wondering if in the sikh
scriptures they it's monotheist right
and you know a lot of people say you
know these people believed in islam or
believed in the prophet
then what was the point of these sikh
scriptures like what was the point of
sikhism like what was their agenda if
they already believed in islam
okay very good question
right
so this is the belief right and um
uh i'm taking this from uh
the late jagras thing okay and we have
the video
him agreeing to this and i believe there
are other videos and other six also
believe this
they believe this
before the ggs
all belief system and all religions had
the truth but they did not add the
complete truths
so when the ggs came down then the
complete truth was given
that's number one right number two
right they make this claim
that the prophet saw allah
was a true prophet
he was he brought the message from god
but then
he got corrupted he got selfish
right
yeah i mean you see
uh before continuing you know if you're
gonna make claims like that without uh
giving evidence i mean just saying that
oh our guru said it or this person said
it this person said it and if we say
something you can't get mad man
right if we if you say this to our
prophet and we say something to your
prophet and then you want to get mad
that's not right bro right i mean come
on right if you can dish it out then you
can take it in
so
um
that is the reason why they believe that
the
the foolproof you know the guru granth
sahib needed to come right um
there are many authors
many people
whose writing were put into the guru
into the gts
okay even the muslims uh bhagat khabib
mardana okay all these people were
muslims they were
sufi muslims no doubt right but they
were muslims
this i can't comprehend that
like
if allah the one true god this truth
right if he wants to give the truth
why does he give the truth just 500
years ago what about
the thousands and thousands years ago
right
that mankind has lived
and died
because now for them it's very easy
tomorrow when they stand in front of
allah and allah ask them questions to
judge them they will say it's easy to
answer them you did not give us the full
truth don't blame us you can't throw us
in hell now
it's your fault you did not give us the
full truth
right
how did we know after a
billion years only then you're gonna
bring down the full truth so you can't
blame earth and and punish us now
so it is it is it is it is um
i i just don't think
logically that that god would have done
that
it's a contradiction it's like when
ahmadis say that you know we still
believe the prophet saws was the final
prophet
but then we also have this guy mirza
galama it makes no sense
makes no sense really makes no sense
okay right because we believe as muslims
right as learned muslims alhamdulillah
we believe look when adam ali when adam
alayhis salaam came down
right then then the full truth was given
to him
and then it got corrupted and then uh
the zaboor came down
right then he got corrupted and then
allah gave the injured
and then he got corrupted and then
done
allah given the quran and here allah
says in only in the quran you'll find
this right you will not find this in the
in any other uh uh
scriptures i can dare to say that that
allah will not say this in any other
scripture what it says is it is us
who brought down the scripture and it is
us who will preserve it
so we know that it's not gonna be any
other scripture because this time allah
says that he will preserve it
so this is the only one that you need
and nothing else
i know bro you got anything to say
um
yeah what do you what do you what advice
would you have to brothers and sisters
that
are thinking of reverting or are revert
themselves but
their whole family their whole history
just
politically ideologically just not in
line with
islam and they feel like what if i have
to pick now
right
i think i think the best advice i can
give short
is that
read your scripture whoever you may be a
hindu
a christian
right be learned on your scripture and
then go to the quran study the quran
right look at the life of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam city the life
ask your friends right
because
the truth is not
difficult to find
no i mean people that already accept the
truth they are they already know either
they're gonna revert or they already
reverted but
they're like bro what about my family
you know it's like islam fundamentally
is you know sikhism is anti right so
well
that's maybe like how was your
experience
like okay yeah uh
although it's a hard question to answer
but uh
alhamdulillah right um
if you have already accepted islam or
you want to accept islam right
here's the thing
your lord comes first
right allah comes first i know a sister
who is actually
alhamdulillah thank you brother for
asking me this question i know a sister
who has just reported
and she
is uh she doesn't have money okay she's
like i think about 18 years old so she
uh
depends on her parents right and her
parents are strict hindus strict hindus
right
um that
they would probably kill her but it will
go to that extent
so she's very afraid she can't read the
quran she can't perform her prayers she
has to basically live like a cafe
she has to eat book whenever the parents
could focus the ebook so she is feeling
very very very masha'allah i don't know
so she asked me for uh for my uh my
opinion one but so um
i told her look
number one you have to understand that
allah knows everything allah knows all
and allah would not make it hard on you
allah says that he will only test
someone
who is that person that individual is
able to accept the text
okay
and there are many things that goes into
the quran of the teachings of the
teachings of allah and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it's so easy i told your sister did you
know
you can lie down and you can perform
your salah
in your condition
right you can do it
you can do it no one would ever no one
would ever think someone lying down and
say oh he's performing salah she's
performing salah
no one will ever do that right so uh
learn to take your wudu you can take
your wudu do perform your salah okay
in terms of uh eating pork right try to
not do it
but if you're being tested right it's a
different story but try not to do it you
always have options right you always
have options until you don't have
options
as simple as that the uyghur muslims in
china you know being force-fed they
can't control that
right
i mean there's always options until you
don't have options
if your option is dying
killing yourself or eating then you have
to eat
right because that is intel it then
comes down to your intellect you have to
eat of course you don't eat till you are
like you know
just eat enough for you to leave
right
and this is all all
the teachings right so don't force
yourself and then
go look for uh
go look for for people who can uh like
from the government states right
they will probably help you with uh in
terms of
cash flow or place to leave or anything
like that and try to get yourself uh you
know out from the house if this is the
position that you are in
right
maybe uh enroll yourself in a school and
tell your parents you want to stay in in
the dormitory instead of coming back
home
that is one thing right that uh for for
anyone who is revered and um they're
facing this problem for anyone who who
already has the truth
and they want to reword but uh you know
like you say
this doubts about my what about my
parents or about this what about that
yes
your parents are important your family
are important but you have the truth you
you accept the truth first
you do right to your lord to your god
first
right because that's the most important
thing you settle your mistakes
your fault with with god with allah
you take the shahada and you immediately
ask for forgiveness from allah first
okay
then
then
you know you've got all this community
around you where you can sit down you
can talk and you can discuss with them
how do i handle this situation
inshaallah
inshallah
all right so i i have a feeling basics
of sikki is gonna
watch this video they're gonna they're
gonna want like a live debate i'm just
playing but if anyone made it this far
just just smash that like button because
you do realize the people that are in
opposition they're gonna dislike the
hell out of this video
um and brother smith if anyone wants to
contact you or anyone wants to send you
a dm or or anything like that do you
have like an email or someone something
that people can reach out to you guys
yes uh so um
h-a-s-m-e-e-t c-h-a-a-l
that's my facebook um
s-m-e-e-t-c-h-a-a-l
that's my instagram
instagram i'll put all that in the
description box
uh one thing actually that i want to
share so recently what i've done over
here is
with other river brothers as well
we have uh opened up and established a
islamic apologetics academy
where we teach
on how to uh
have discussion intellectually and
present islam without belittling other
religion and uh bringing them down and
so on intellectually yet
all the classes
are completely free we do not charge
anything for the classes
all that we ask from you if you do want
to join us you have to be committed
for at least three months so we have a
syllabus on christianity we have
syllabus on atheism
we have syllabus on buddhism we have
syllabus on hinduism at the moment
insha'allah and we also have syllabus on
ethics of being a dying
how a dying should be
there's a syllabus on everything man
mashallah
inshallah
okay so uh what is the
you can just give me the link i'll put
that in the description box all right uh
yeah
yeah i'll give you the link but i'll
mention it so it's called so it's kum
not kum it's q o o m as in in the quran
right so that's why we took the name
because it says stand and proclaim the
greatness of your lord
right
[Music]
academy kum academy
i'm going to check it out
thank you okay thank you
thank you
i just started right here bro sorry
right here for your time
hi guys if you made it this far
comment down below hashtag come to the
truth
and until next time assalamualaikum
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas
we will go in with our final three with
brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
um